quiero comenzar preguntándoles creen que
la justicia restaurativa y la paz son
sólo temas políticos y judiciales y para
ir adentrándose en esta pregunta quiero
contar una historia
todo comenzó cuando quise conectar con
mi carrera de manera más empática soy
abogada y cuando conocí el mundo de la
justicia restaurativa mi vida cambió por
completo cuando me gradué comencé como
mediadora de conflictos y ahí conocí
todas las posibilidades de la justicia
restaurativa que nos ayudan a responder
esa pregunta aquí les voy a narrar
varias historias para que entendamos que
el conflicto es positivo que la
reparación es necesaria y que la paz se
debe practicar a diario aquí está mi
primer aprendizaje los conflictos son
necesario son positivos nos ayudan a
crecer pero hay que entender que detrás
de ellos hay una historia hay una
persona hay un mundo y hay una necesidad
les cuento que una vez los estudiantes
comenzaron a juntarse cada uno en el
hombro a manera de juego todo empezó a
tornarse más hostil y en algún momento
uno de ellos golpearlos lo tan fuerte
que lo revienta en la cea en ese momento
se gustó del abordaje del canal de
convivencia y cuando hacemos el abordaje
restaurativo le preguntamos bueno al
afectado y tú qué necesitas para que
todo esté bien dice miren yo necesito
tiempo
dijimos guau un niño de 13 años pidiendo
tiempo le dimos el tiempo un mes y medio
después le dimos estás preparado sí o sí
ya estoy preparada en ese momento no
quería aceptar mi responsabilidad quería
que solo fuera de la del otro en este
momento ya estoy preparado para hacerlo
y aquí es donde vamos respondiendo esta
pregunta el conflicto pasa todos los
días en nuestras vidas todos los días
nos ayuda a crecer nos ayuda a estar nos
ayuda a entendernos con el otro pero el
conflicto no solamente es el conflicto
son historias detrás de ese conflicto
que hay que escuchar tenemos que dar un
poquito sin monopolio de querer resolver
los conflictos a los demás y dejárselo
también a los escenarios políticos y
judiciales y poder hacerlo nosotros
mismos o las partes mismas aquí viene un
segundo aprendizaje y es sobre la
responsabilidad y la vergüenza miren la
vergüenza es decir yo soy el malo y
todos lo saben la responsabilidad es
decir yo hice algo malo y yo lo sé y
para explicarles este punto traje dos
casos el primero es de un estudiante que
dice mira lo que pasa es que una vez yo
clase y el profesor desde ese momento
cada inicial la que cappa clase la que
cappa clase y yo ya ni siquiera quiero
volver decir esa niña se convirtió solo
en ese error muy seguramente poder sido
la mejor de la clase pero por ese error
quedó marcada de x
y el segundo caso es que una vez hice un
círculo restaurativa en un colegio en
una zona muy violenta de la ciudad y el
profesor me dieron no ustedes y no va a
poder hacer nada ese salón es súper
difícil en ese momento
entré al salón en el círculo muy
distinto a todo lo que me había narrado
los profesores chicos muy participativos
contentos e inquietos como todos los
niños
y en algún momento les pregunté bueno y
cuál es su materia favorita dijeron
matemáticas el oxígeno y por qué porque
la profesora cada vez que llega aquí
dice que le encanta este salón que nos
ama mucho y que somos los más
inteligentes y aquí es donde podemos
entender que cuando le respondemos a los
demás desde la sanción desde el dolor
desde la ira vamos a recibir lo mismo de
los demás mientras que si respondemos
desde el amor desde la comprensión desde
la tolerancia no vamos a ver solo
errores en los demás sino vamos a ver
oportunidades porque todos todos
cometemos errores y aquí es donde
seguimos respondiendo en esta pregunta
porque nos damos cuenta que esto lo
hacemos a diario avergonzamos casi
siempre a los demás y les decimos
ustedes son ese error y como nos
gustaría que a nosotros tampoco nos
trataran así y cuántas veces hemos dicho
que vamos a cambiar y no lo hacemos
porque ya como que nos han dicho tanto
que somos así que pues para qué
cambiamos y miren cómo se convierte en
algo que hacemos todos los días
y por último viene mi tercer y gran
aprendizaje que es la reparación
resulta que el noveno un niño
al baño del colegio y un todo el baño
coge los papeles del banco absolutamente
todo cuando lo abordamos dijo pues sí yo
fui pero realmente no sé por qué fue yo
quería como divertirme voy a estar bueno
cuando hicimos el abordaje restaurativo
me quedé con él una tarde sin saber que
ponerlo a hacer yo no quería castigarlo
yo no quería sancionarlo yo lo quería
estigmatizar pero como lo responsabilice
en ese momento se me ocurrió llevarlo a
hablar con la señora del aseo que
precisamente estaba en el baño y dijo
vamos bajamos y él empieza a hablar
súper bien con él ya contento él ya el
día le cuenta que se va a graduar del
colegio y le dice que lo que ella
necesite él con mucho gusto y momento a
otro me dice diana será que yo le puedo
ayudar a la señora del aseo a hacer la
limpieza él claro si tú quieres la
señora del aseo le pasa todos los
implementos y él empieza a decir no
puedo creer que mis compañeros dejen
este salón tan sucio este baño tan sucio
y que la señora le toque todos los días
lavar todo
en ese momento terminamos hicimos una
reflexión y a la semana me buscan unos
compañeros de el mst a la que le hiciste
tiempo que le hice porque porque cada
vez que entramos al baño el inicio todo
el mundo oiga cuidado que la señora la
sobre toca muy duro cuidemos el baño es
responsabilidad de todos y aquí es donde
entendemos cosas muy importantes porque
la justicia restaurativa lo que hace es
reparar algo que se dañó la justicia
punitiva es castigar una norma que se
quebrantó y ahí es la diferencia abismal
entre estas dos justicias es necesario
saber que la justicia restaurativa
quiere reparar lo dañado si no solamente
hemos transgredido una norma hemos
dañado algo y aquí es donde terminamos
de responder esta pregunta inicial
porque tenemos que entender que la
justicia restaurativa y la paz se
construyen es a diario es en el diario
vivir la paz es algo que se va haciendo
todos los días como un proceso no es
fácil pero es posible y es necesario
y ahí tenemos que entender que el
conflicto totalmente es positivo que el
diálogo es necesario que las partes
pueden hablar deben hablar y se les debe
creer y escuchar sin juzgar y así
podremos entender que estos temas no
solo son del escenario judicial y
político sino que también son de nuestro
diario vive la justicia la justicia sana
así que déjense sanar y sanen lo que han
dañado de todo lo anterior he aprendido
muchísimas cosas sobre la justicia
restaurativa por eso creé un proyecto
que se llama el arte de hacer las paces
un lugar para que todos construyamos las
formas más restaurativas de solucionar
conflictos entendiendo tres cosas la
primera es que tenemos derecho a errar
tenemos derecho al error sin él sin el
miedo al castigo porque el castigo no
nos garantiza aprendizaje sino más dolor
y miedo todos tenemos derecho a
equivocarnos pero más tenemos derecho a
reparar y tres tenemos derecho a vivir
un futuro
un futuro con los aprendizajes del
pasado sin la estigmatización y la
humillación así que necesitamos un mundo
en donde reflexionemos que la justicia
restaurativa y la construcción de paz es
un arte del diario vivir no un tema
político y judicial
vivamos entornos desde la humanidad y la
justicia restaurativa como un arte de
hacer las bases muchas gracias